this course will help you learn what you
need to implement graph algorithms and
use them to solve coding challenges
alvin's dynamic programming course is
one of the most popular courses on our
channel and now he's back to teach you
graph algorithms hey programmers i'm
alvin from instructi welcome to our
course on graphs in particular this is
going to be about graphs for your
technical interviews of course graphs
are a very common topic when it comes to
those technical interviews in particular
what i want to emphasize throughout this
course is the handful of patterns that
come up time and time again on those
technical interviews in just about two
and a half hours i'm gonna give you all
the tools you need to basically cover
i'd say about eighty percent of all
graph problems and so what do i have in
store for this course well i think the
key to victory for your data structures
and algorithms and especially your
graphs is to visualize things right so
we're going to do is trace through a lot
of different algorithms and be sure to
understand them at a high level and that
means going through different animations
here i think graphs have a pretty bad
rep for being a difficult topic because
to a beginner you can have very very
different narratives around a problem
and not really understand they're all
really based on a graph premise so we're
going to realize that a bunch of
different things could be understood as
graphs
so when it comes to the prerequisites of
this course i'm going to assume that you
know nothing about graphs but you do
know how to code right so i'm going to
have the expectation that you understand
some recursion so as you work through
the course and learn about different
graph patterns we're going to use those
patterns to solve some very classic
interview problems about graphs right
i'm going to give you plenty of
opportunity to practice these patterns
and different problems that way you'll
be ready whenever you have them on a
technical interview what i love about
the topic of graphs is just using a
handful of different algorithms you can
cover the majority of graph problems
right for every graph problem that we
cover we're going to split it up into
two sections section one is going to be
about the approach for the video so
we're going to go over the strategy and
overall theory and be sure to sketch out
a nice meaningful picture we're also
going to talk about the complexity of
the algorithm in the approach video
following every approach we're also
going to implement the code of course
i'm going to be writing all of my code
in javascript you'll be able to follow
along in any language that you like so
that means occasionally i'll be
switching to my code editor where you of
course can follow along
we're also going to be sure to provide
links in description as well as links on
screen that way you can formally read
the prompts for every problem as well as
look at the different test cases all
right i think that's enough introduction
for now let's hop right into the course
all right programmers let's jump right
into the course i want to start by
giving you some background about your
graphs we're going to go over the graph
basics that you need to start attacking
problems in a technical interview
so first off what is a graph a graph is
really just a collection of nodes and
edges
so with respect to nodes you can
visualize them as typically just some
circles with some data inside of them so
i'll put some letter values in my nodes
over here
and when we refer to edges that would be
just any connections between nodes so
for example there was a connection
between a and c it would look something
like this right what i can formally say
is there's an edge between a and c i can
create many edges between any nodes i
want within this graph
another word you might hear out in the
wild when it comes to describing nodes
is you might hear the word vertex being
used right they're really the same thing
in this course i'll stick to the word
node and an edge is just a connection
between a pair of nodes that's really
all a graph is at a high level where
things get interesting is how we can use
this graph framework to actually solve a
problem right so if you think of these
nodes as just things and the edges as
relationships a graph is great at
describing the relationship between
things for example we can say that the
nodes here are cities and edges would be
roads connecting cities or in a similar
way maybe our nodes here are courses and
then the edges represent prerequisites
and so in the future we're going to use
graphs as a way to illustrate and frame
some narrative problem
let's talk about this graph in
particular here i really have drawn a
directed graph
and that's because i have some
arrowheads along the edges that would be
in comparison to an undirected graph
here i have really the same structure
except i don't have any arrowheads on
the edges here
and that means that there is no
directionality to it right if i look at
the directed graph let's say i was at
the node a well then i can travel to b
or c let's say i move to c
however once i'm at c i cannot travel to
a i can only travel to e right that's
because i have to obey the direction of
the arrow heads here
if i take a look at my undirected graph
let's say i was currently situated at
the c note over here then i do have the
option of traveling to either a or e
right so if i travel to a that's all
good i can even travel back to c so
think of a undirected graph as a two-way
street for now we'll just continue on
with our directed version let me also
introduce some useful terminology we can
use when talking about the nodes in our
graph if i was currently situated at
this a node i can refer to b and c as
neighbor nodes right so a neighbor node
is really any node that's accessible
through an edge of course obeying the
direction of the edge in other words if
i was currently situated at the c node
then i only have one neighbor of e right
if i'm at the c note then i won't
consider a a neighbor
awesome
when you visualize graph algorithms you
should really sketch a picture that
looks just like this right literally
draw nodes of circles and arrows as your
edges here however when it comes to how
we implement this algorithm in some code
we're going to have to represent it in a
more programmatic way right so in my
brain i think of this image of like
nodes and arrows between them however in
my program i'm going to use typically an
adjacency list it's probably our
preferred way to represent graph
information right so depending on the
programming language of choice you're
going to use typically we would use some
hashmap data structure to represent an
adjacency list really you're looking
forward to using some constant time a
lookup data structure that has a key
value pair mapping right so if you're in
javascript that'll be an object if
you're in python that'll be a dictionary
if you're in a language like java or c
you'll be using an unordered map
looking at this hash map i've drawn or
this adjacency list the keys of this
adjacency list are going to be every
node in my graph right so i just have
all of the node values
a through f laid out as the keys
however if you look at the corresponding
values the values are actually going to
be an array right so if i look at this
very first entry
it says that i have a node of a
and then in the array i've populated all
of the neighbors of a that is a has two
neighbors of b and c that's why i have
this correspondence within my adjacency
list
that holds true for every entry within
my adjacency list so for example let's
say i look at the entry for e so i go to
the spot in my jc list where the key is
e it only has one outgoing edge to b
that's why the array for e only has b
inside of it
one thing to also note is even if a node
has no neighbors it should still appear
as a key within my adjacency list for
example if you look at the d node d has
no outgoing edges that's why its
neighbor array is empty however it
should still at least appear as a key
within my adjacency list right that way
i can still know that the d node exists
so at the start of the course we'll
usually be taking in adjacency list as
the information to represent a graph
right but as we sketch through things on
the whiteboard we should be visualizing
them using a nice picture like this
awesome so let's actually jump into our
first pair of algorithms to me the
must-know algorithm for a graph is
really going to be to do some sort of
traversal on it
why don't we start by talking about a
depth first traversal something you may
have heard of before right now we're
going to talk about the depth first
reversal algorithm that operates on a
graph
so let's start by understanding at a
high level what ordered a depth first
reversal would give you
so let's say i had some starting node
and i'm going to choose a as my starting
node right so i'm going to color it here
in yellow if i was following a depth
first reversal now that i've you know
chosen as my starting point i can either
hit b or c next i'm just going to commit
to using b so let's say i had the
sequence so far of a comma b
and at this point if i was truly
following a depth first traversal i must
go deeper to the d node in other words i
don't go to the c node yet
cool that would be a true depth first
reversal right and at this point now
that i've bottomed out a d d is a dead
end right i can't travel to f from d
because that would be disobeying the
arrow head and so now i can move to that
other neighbor of c
and from here the algorithm would
continue right i go from c to e and then
e to b and technically i would have to
double traverse some nodes like b and d
over here
so overall in this yellow coloring i
have colored the full region that a
depth first reversal would explore
starting at a
notice that if you started at a it would
be impossible to reach f and that's kind
of normal right that's kind of why we
use these traversal algorithms it can
tell you whether or not you can travel
between some nodes and we'll see that
literal problem later on right so you're
probably wondering you know exactly how
do we implement this but for now i just
want to stay focused on the order that
we got right so just regarding our debt
first reversal if we remember the first
three you know iterations of the
algorithm we hit the sequence of abd
right that's indicative of a depth first
reversal
now let's compare that to the breath
first variant so i'm going to lay down
the same exact graph we're also going to
start a traversal at the a node but this
time follow a breath first order so i
have a first and let's say you know i
chose b as my next node when it comes to
a breath first reversal it doesn't
matter like which you know initial
neighbor you choose so i'm just going to
choose b
but now that i've chosen b if i was
following a true breadth first reversal
i must hit c next right and that's the
main difference between our depth first
and breadth first reversals for the same
graph my depth first would start abd
whereas my breath first would start abc
and so you're probably wondering is is
there any importance between this nuance
right when would i prefer depth first
over breath first or vice versa
either a depth first or a breath first
traversal would explore the same exact
nodes within a graph however it would
explore them in a different order right
and this is more obvious to see when we
have a larger graph with way more edges
and so let's look at how that first
traversal explores again but this time
on a much larger graph let's take a look
at this one so i'm going to choose some
random node as a starting point let's
say i chose this node in yellow
if i was doing a depth first traversal
what i'm going to do is you know pick a
direction and travel in that same
direction as far as possible before
switching directions so let's say i move
to the right at this point i would have
to continue moving toward the right
until i can't move to the right any
longer at which point i have to choose
some new direction so let's say it was
downward
i would keep doing that until i can't
move downward anymore and so i'd have to
move to the left now and i would keep
chasing this single path in a very deep
direction
and so that's behavior indicative of a
depth first reversal right you're
exploring one direction as far as
possible before switching directions
let's compare that to a breath first
traversal so let's say i started at the
same note in pink if i was following a
breath first reversal it would look
something like this from the starting
point i would explore all of the
immediate neighbors of this node kind of
in a circle like this now i just keep
applying that behavior
so what you notice about the breath
first reversal is it'll tend to explore
you know all directions evenly right
instead of just favoring one direction
all the way through that's really the
only difference between a depth first
and a breath first reversal later on the
course i'll bring up explicit problems
where you might prefer one over the
other all right but for now what i want
to do is give you all the background you
need so you can actually build this
algorithm we'll kind of talk about
things at a high level consider this the
pseudo code then of course we'll express
it in some javascript code later on so
when it comes to actually implementing
and code these two algorithms the key is
to understand that a depth first
traversal uses a stack and a breadth
first traversal uses a cue recall that a
stack is something where you add to the
top and remove from the top as well
whereas a cue is something where you add
to the back and remove from the front
and it gives you two very different
orderings that's really the only
difference between these two algorithms
so let's start by tracing through our
depth first traversal of course using a
stack so i'm going to use a slightly
different graph
and to visualize my stack i'm going to
use this bar to represent the bottom of
my stack obviously
for me at least i think of a stack as
some vertical data structure
cool so let's say i just arbitrarily
chose a as my starting node to perform
my depth first traversal right in the
long run just want to print out all
different node values within this graph
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take my starting node of a i'm just
going to immediately initialize it onto
my stack so right now a is the only
thing on my stack it's also at the top
of my stack and now i can enter the flow
of the main algorithm here because i
have a stack what i can only do is
remove the top of my stack so that means
i pop off a from the stack and consider
the a node my current node being looked
at right at this point let's say i print
out a to my console
and from here what i want to do is
consider a's neighbors right so if i
look at the c node what i should do is
just push c to the stack then also push
b to the stack right and it doesn't
matter like in which order you push
these neighbors if i wanted to hit b
first then i'm going to push them second
right awesome that would end like my
first iteration of this depth first
traversal
cool so at this point i can look at my
stack and my stack still has some data
on it so what i should do is again pop
the top of my stack so i'm going to pop
b off my stack and that becomes my
current i'm also going to print it out
at this point i look at b's neighbors b
has one neighbor of d and so i push d to
the top of the stack notice that because
i have a stack d ends up on top of the c
right and so now when i get to another
iteration when i pop the top of my stack
i look at the d node as my current
right and i can print out d
and this feels good because so far my
print order would be abd notice that i
kind of pursued that single path deeply
following abd
but i have to look at these neighbors i
can take f and just push f to the top of
my stack
next iteration my stack is still not
empty so i should do is pop the top f is
now my current i can print out f
but f has no neighbors so f isn't going
to push anything else to the top of the
stack right
at this point i get to this next pass
and i pop the top of my stack and that
means c is now my current i can print
out c's value
and then i can look at c's neighbors and
i just push e to the top of my stack on
this last iteration i pop the top of my
stack e is now my current i print out e
since e has no neighbors i don't push
anything else to the top of my stack
and at this point i've reached the state
where my stack is empty and that means
my algorithm is done right that means
you explored as far as possible within
your graph notice that it might not
necessarily be the case that you're able
to hit every node of the graph in this
particular example it was possible
though
awesome so let's redo that trace using
our breadth-first algorithm which means
we just adjust things slightly and we
use a queue order right remember that a
queue is a first in first out data
structure meaning things enter to the
back and then they leave from the front
and so let's say i use this arrow to
represent the directionality of my queue
right and i start the algorithm in the
same way for my breadth first reversal
let's say i want it to begin at node a
so i just initialize my q with a
cool so i start by removing the front of
my queue so a becomes my current node i
can print out a as well
and now i consider a's neighbors right
so i consider b and c if i wanted to
travel to b before c then i should push
b
to my q first right so i add b to the
back of my q
right and i should also add c to the
back of my queue right
and that would actually end my first
iteration
so now i look at my queue it still has
some stuff on it so i remove the front
of my queue that means b becomes my
current
of course i print out b
now i consider b's neighbors so i just
look at the d node and i push d to the
back of the queue since d enters through
the back it ends up behind the c and
that's really important behavior
next iteration i remove the front of my
queue so my current is now c right i can
print out c
and then look at c's neighbors of just e
and i add e to the back of the q which
means that in the order of my q e ends
up behind d
on my next iteration i remove d from the
q
and i print out d and add its neighbor
of f to the back of my q
next iteration i remove e from the front
of my queue print it out since e has no
neighbors e is not going to add anything
else to the back of the queue
and of course finally f leaves the front
of my queue
i print out f f has no neighbors at
which point now my q is totally empty
and since our q is empty that would be
the end of our algorithm
all right and that's all there is to our
depth first and breadth first algorithms
they're going to be the nice baseline
code that we use to solve many different
graph problems i think that's enough
theory for now what i want to do is now
switch to my code editor where we can
actually implement these in javascript
hey programmers so here i am in my
editor what i want to do is now show you
how to implement those depth first and
breadth first algorithms so we'll start
with the depth first and my goal is
really just to build a function that
will print out all of my values in the
graph according to a depth first
traversal right so i'm going to define
this function depth first print
make it an arrow function
javascript it's going to take in the
graph which is going to be given as a
nice adjacency list and this is actually
the same graph in that last example we
traced out i'm also going to need to
specify some starting node here i'll
call it a source node i'm going to begin
in the traversal starting at that node
cool and so we know inherent to a depth
first traversal is going to be a stack
so i'll show you how to implement this
iteratively which means you need an
explicit stack for me in javascript
that's as simple as just using a
javascript array right
i'll make it empty at the start
and i can use this array as a stack if i
just commit to using operations that
manipulate the same end of the array in
other words if i just use push and pop
that will always manipulate the end of
the array right removing and adding to
the end of that array
what i want to actually be sure to do is
i want to initialize the stack with my
starting node that is with my source
node remember that like a node here is
really just designated by
some character
cool and when it comes to designing like
the main loop for the algorithm here you
want to keep running the algorithm while
the stack is not empty in other words
while stack.length is bigger than zero
that i have to keep running that's very
reminiscent to what we expressed on the
whiteboard
so when it comes to performing like a
single iteration of this depth first
what i want to do is remove the top of
my stack so if i do stack.pop
that will remove the last item of an
array in this case like the top of my
stack and also return it to me so i'm
going to save that to a variable i'll
call it my current
and so this point would actually be a
great opportunity to just print out that
current so all console.log
current
right so looking at you know this
example over here
since i initialized a stack to contain
just the source node of a on the very
first iteration this y loop i would of
course pop out a then i would print it
out all right and from that point what i
want to do is consider a's neighbors of
b and c so if i want to look at like the
array associated with a i can just key
into my graph right because my graph is
an object right now so if i say graph
square bracket
current
right if current is a that means graph
square bracket current would give me
back this array i want to iterate
through every node or every neighbor in
that array so i'm going to nest a loop
here i'm going to say 4 let neighbor
of that array so if you're unfamiliar in
javascript if you just use a forward of
loop that will iterate in order through
an array so now i'm hitting neighbor as
b and neighbor sc
what i want to do with those neighbors
is simply push them to the top of my
stack
so that will just be stack dot push
and push this neighbor
awesome i'm going to be sure to push
every single neighbor that it has so
sometimes i'll have two neighbors other
times i'll have one neighbor or even no
neighbors
that's really all there is to
implementing a nice baseline depth first
print something that i do want to point
out my favorite way to implement this
algorithm is to consider like processing
your node when it leaves the stack not
when it enters the stack in other words
i usually write like my print statement
right after something is popped and the
thing that i pop is exactly what i print
right
so let's go ahead and give this a run
see what we get
it looks like in my terminal i got the
order of a c e b d f which you'll notice
is slightly different from what i
expected from over here
however this would be also a valid
depth-first traversal we have to bear in
mind is you know depending on like the
arbitrary order of
values within the same neighbors array
you could tend a different direction at
first right the most important thing i
look for when it comes to verifying a
depth first is to make sure that i you
know chase the same direction before
switching directions right so since i
started out with ac
so i go a and then to a c over here the
next move would be going to e and that's
exactly what happened in my code right
and then once i hit e e is actually a
dead end so then i can go on to my other
lateral neighbor like b right
and so i can contrive the same order i
expected here if i just flipped
this right so i put c followed by b
i'll give that a run they're both valid
uh depth first traversals
let's see what we got now cool now i get
the exact order of abdfce
and really think about why that is right
so let's say that i just popped out a
from my stack so i printed out a that's
nothing fancy right and then from there
i start iterating through the array
that's associated with a right so in the
first iteration i iterate through c
right if i push c on the stack let's say
this is the bottom of my stack if i push
c on the stack it's right here
then followed by that i push b on the
stack now b is on top since b is on top
i know like the next top level iteration
of this while loop i would remove b and
that's going to be the next node i visit
and so they're really both depth first
reversals
nice
so two things to note you're definitely
going to use a stack to implement depth
for reversal and you can use the stack
in a few different ways right so here
i'm using like an explicit like array as
a stack and i'm implementing this using
some iterative code right so using a few
loops right what you can also do is
implement depth first recursively
because i know any recursion uses the
underlying call stack so let me show you
how to implement that as well
and when it comes to you know having all
these different tools in your arsenal i
would definitely practice both the
iterative and recursive flavors we'll
see that later on this course
so let's say i wanted to solve the same
problem but now recursively
it's actually going to be a less code so
i'm going to have the same sort of
arguments here i'm going to have the
graph which is the adjacency list as
well as a source node consider like the
source node as like your current
location so if i'm at some node maybe
the first thing i should do is just
print out myself right print out this
node so i'll do is console.log
this source node
and that feels good just from the get
because
when we actually do a top-level call to
this recursive function they're passing
in a as the source node so i do want to
begin a as the first node in my print
and then from there i need to look at
a's neighbors well if you want to look
at ace neighbors like before just key
into the graph adjacency list using
that node right and this would give me
an array of c and b now i just iterate
through that array so i'll say 4 let
neighbor of that array and at this point
what i want to do is now do the
recursion right so i make a recursive
call on each of these neighbors so for
me that means just call depth first
print
you give the same graph right the graph
object doesn't change but you should
change like the source node now you want
to pass in that neighbor as the source
node and you're going to make a
recursive call for every neighbor in
that array
this would actually be all we need let's
go ahead and just run this version
give that a run over here
it looks like now we get the order ace
bdf and that's really again another type
of depth first print right it's not
exactly this order because this time we
chased c first right we went a c e
if i wanted to get exactly this ordering
in my recursion then i would have to put
b first
right
really same sort of pattern though let's
give that another run
good abd fce
one thing i want to bring up about this
recursive depth first is it has no
explicit base case meaning there's no
obvious like if statement that just like
returns like you typically see in most
recursion that's because in this problem
i have an implicit base case when a node
like e is a dead end right let's say my
current source coming in is e well then
when i iterate in this for loop i'm
iterating through this empty array that
means i have zero iterations if you have
zero iterations then you never make a
recursive call right so that's the same
thing as having a base case right a base
case is really just a scenario where we
don't have a recursive call so that's
how this code still works all right so
now you know how to implement depth
first in two ways right iterative and
recursively and they both use definitely
a stack let me now show you how to
implement your breath first right so
i'll comment out some of this code
now we'll do a nice breath first
give myself some room over here
so for a breath first we'll want to
solve this one iteratively and it's
really only possible iteratively right
because i know a breadth first traversal
demands a cue if you try to like
implement a breadth first reversal using
some recursion then under the hood
there's some stack data structure that's
going to fight against the queue order
that you want right so for breath first
reversal you're always typically going
to be writing some iterative code so
some loops right let me define this i'll
say breath first
print
take in the full graph adjacency list as
well as the source node
and i want to initialize my queue
with that source node again the queue
here is just going to be an array in
javascript so i'll say const q equals an
array that begins with just the source
node
awesome i'm going to use this q by just
committing to two specific methods on my
arrays in javascript so if i use
array.shift that removes the first
element of an array if i do array.push
that adds to the last position of an
array and using those two methods in
combination would give me a nice cue
where i add to one end and remove from
the other end
so like before we're gonna have a while
loop and we're gonna iterate while our q
is not empty and so while q dot length
is bigger than zero nice
and same thing as our iterative you know
depth first you want to start by just
removing the front of your queue so i'll
say q
dot shift that will remove the first
element as well as return it to me so i
can save in a variable i like to call it
current just like the whiteboard right
and then from there maybe i'll print it
out so i'll console.log this current
node
and from here just consider your
neighbors right so if i key into my
graph using this current node that would
give me an array of its neighbors
i want to loop the reach of those
neighbors so i can say four i'll say let
neighbor
of that array
and for that neighbor i want to add them
to the back of my queue so for me that
would mean simply q dot push i'm going
to go ahead and push that neighbor
awesome so i remove from the front and i
add to the back
so that looks pretty good let's go ahead
and give it a run and actually before i
do that i'm going to change the order of
this i'm going to put the c and b
again it doesn't really matter the
relative order of your neighbors i just
want this exact output we'll talk about
why that is right give that a run so i
get acb edf just like i expected acb edf
right
so let's say we're on the first
iteration of this breath first print i
know that i would have just removed a
because i initialized a on the queue
right so my current is a
and i print out a and then from there i
start iterating through this array right
so in the first iteration i have c
that means i put c into my queue right
and then afterwards i put b
if you put
c and then b that means c is at the
front of the queue which is why on the
second iteration i have c first
all right so that's how you can
manipulate potentially the lateral order
of a breath first print awesome and
that's all there is to this traversal
algorithm what i really want to
emphasize is especially if you look at
the
apples to apples iterative code
you compare your depth first versus your
breath first it's almost identical code
you're really just changing how you
access items in your array right you
either pop or push or you shift and push
other than that the whole like structure
of this code is identical right all
right so that's our introduction on
depth first and breadth first for our
graphs in the next section we're going
to start to solve a problem right which
will be really fun by just utilizing
this code as our baseline tool and in
that section i also promise to start
doing the analysis for big o of these
algorithms so let's jump back to that
whiteboard hey programmers welcome back
right now let's go over the approach for
this has path problem
so in this problem we're going to take
in an adjacency list representing a
graph
for this problem and really all graph
problems you definitely want to
visualize this one with a picture and so
what we'll do is we'll interpret each
key of this adjacency list as
representing a distinct node
and if i look at any particular list i
can see that this f node should point to
g and i and they do tell us in this
problem that i have a directed graph so
i'm going to draw arrowheads on these
edges here so f points to g as well as f
points to i and i'll create similar
edges based on the information in the
given graph so i end up with an image
like this and so they tell us that this
is a directed graph that explains the
arrowheads but they also tell us that
this graph is acyclic so if you're
unfamiliar acyclic just means no cycles
that kind of begs the question what is a
cycle in a graph
so a cycle would be some path through
nodes where i can end up where i once
started in other words if i started at
the a node over here then i can go to b
then from there i can go to c then back
to a and so on and so forth so if i did
a traversal on the cyclic graph i would
get an infinite loop what they're saying
is our graph input is guaranteed to be
directed so it has arrowheads but also
acyclic so we won't have to consider any
infinite cycles here
that being said in this problem we also
want to take in not only the graph
information but also a source and
destination node
what we want to do is return true or
false indicating whether or not we can
travel from the source node to the
destination node in other words is there
a path that exists between those two
nodes
for this problem you can use either a
depth first or a breath first search to
actually solve the problem here i'll
trace through in this approach video
just the depth first search but in the
walkthrough i'll be sure to code it up
both ways
so let's say i started at my source node
i know that if i was doing a depth first
reversal i can either choose the i or g
let's say i happen to choose the genex
now i have no choice right if i'm doing
truly a depth first i should go deeper
to the h so then i hit this h and as i
traverse through these different nodes i
need to ask myself if my current node is
equal to my destination so far that
hasn't been true at this point i've
bottomed out with my h node i can't
travel any deeper so now i can move
laterally to a node like i
at this point from i can either move to
a k or a g let's say by luck i just
happened to go to the g this would
actually bring me down a path i've
explored previously which we can
optimize later on but wouldn't be too
much of a big deal
eventually if i continue this depth
first search through the graph i would
end up at a node that matches my
destination at which point i can return
true signifying that there must be some
path from f to k just doing a depth
first search and as we do the depth
first search it's really important that
you obey the directions of your arrows
so i should never try to travel
upstream
so that was a scenario where we were
able to find a path from source to
destination that's why we returned true
let's reset and say that now i should
return false alright so let's say my
source was j so i start at j and i'm
trying to get to my destination of f
if i start at a depth first reversal
here sorry my j node travel to the i
node at this point i can hit either the
grk let's say i happen to hit the k at
this point i've bottomed out so now i
can move to the g and then from there to
the h
and at this point there's actually
nowhere else i can go right so if i
finish my traversal or through the graph
using either a depth first or breath
first and i never hit my destination
then i can just return false right it
must be the case that there is no such
path from my source to my destination
when it comes to implementing the depth
first and breadth first reversals on
this graph it's going to be exactly what
we're used to you can either use a stack
and solve it recursively or you can do
it iteratively and use a q in which case
you'd be doing the breadth-first
traversal
if we talk about the complexity of this
let's say that n is the number of nodes
of our graph a common thing that you can
also do with these graph problems is
define e as the number of edges here an
edge just refers to a connection between
two nodes basically just the arrows so
if we use these two terms of number
nodes and number edges we would have a
time complexity of o of e o of the
number of edges that's because we would
have to travel through every single edge
of our graph here the space complexity
would be based on the number of nodes
right if i solved it recursively or even
iteratively with some sort of a depth
first stack then the worst case i would
have to have every single node on the
stack right likewise if i solve it
iteratively with a breadth first they
would have every single node on the
queue
so that's just one way we can define the
terms for analyzing the time and space
of this graph typically for graph
problems another acceptable way to
analyze the time and space of your
algorithm is to just use a single
variable and just define n as the number
of nodes that's because if you say n is
the number of nodes then we can also say
that n squared would be the number of
edges remember that big o is about the
worst case let's imagine the worst case
graph let's say i just had these nodes
of abc
well if i wanted to create as many edges
as possible how would i just create a
single edge well an edge is just a
connection between
two nodes
so you could just really draw an edge
for every pair of nodes in your graph
something like this and that's why we
can say that n squared is the number of
edges of any particular graph and so if
you just wanted to use n to define the
complexity here then you could say that
your time is going to be o of n squared
your space complexity would still be o
of n
do note that these are both two valid
ways for defining the complexity for
very typical graph problems now that
being said i think this is pretty
straightforward let's hop into the
walkthrough video where we'll actually
implement both a depth first and a
breath first solution for these i'll see
you there
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over a javascript solution for
this has path problem
and so we'll jump right in we're going
to start by solving this one using a
depth first reversal which i know
requires some underlying stack data
structure i'll just implement it using
recursion so i can leverage the call
stack to get my ordering
and so i'm going to solve this
recursively i'm going to consider my
source
argument as like my current position
during the traversal and so i can have a
base case and check all right if my
source is equal to my destination then i
must have found the thing i'm looking
for so just return true this base case
signifies that i found my destination so
there must exist a path and so i return
true always paying attention to the type
that they want us to return for this
function
let's say it's not true well then i need
to keep looking so what i should do is
consider my current node which is source
consider its neighbors
if i key into my adjacency list i know
that this is going to be an object so if
i key into it using my source that would
give me an array of all of its neighbors
so for example let's say i was staring
at this one
if my current source was f
and i say graph square bracket f i would
get back an array of g and i
so now i want to look through the
neighbors right so what i can say over
here is turn this into a loop and say 4
let neighbor
of
[Music]
those neighbors
i want to traverse to them which means i
call recursively right call has path
keep your graph the same but update your
current position now i'm going to be
situated at the neighbor and the
destination stays the same i always have
the same goal to get to
i'm solving this one recursively so
think about what type this is going to
return i know it's going to give back
boolean right it's going to tell me
whether or not there is some path
between my neighbor and the destination
right
so if there's some connecting point or
some connecting path between my neighbor
and the destination then i know that
there must be some path from my source
to the destination because your source
is definitely next to your neighbor
right so there would be a path between
all of us and so what i'll do is
check if this recursive call
returns true i'll make it explicit here
maybe it's clear
and so if there is some path through my
neighbor to the destination
then i can return true just pass that
true upward because once i find a path
you can just exit out and return that
true all the way back to the top level
caller
but let's say that this call returned
false that means that there is no path
through my neighbor to the destination
but it could be the case that some other
neighbor is actually going to work out
and so what i don't want to do is just
say like else return false you should be
able to immediately catch that code like
this is suspect because there's no point
of having a for loop then right if in
either case you're always going to
return then you're never going to have a
second iteration of this for loop right
so if
i don't find a path through my neighbor
so if this call returns false then
that's okay just continue on to the next
iteration and search through your other
neighbor
that begs the question where should we
return false it needs to be after the
for loop so only after i search through
all of my neighbors and i never find a
winning path should i return
false that would be our nice depth first
traversal let's give that a test run
awesome there we have it one thing to
bear in mind here we are leveraging the
assumptions in the problem right they
tell us straight up that the graph
you're going to be given is acyclic so
there are no cycles so that's why in our
code we didn't really worry about
getting trapped in an infinite loop in
our upcoming problems we'll have harder
graphs that actually deal with that
cyclic case but for now this is a good
baseline solution
while we're here let's also do a
breath first solution
which you know by now should be
iterative right there's no way to do
like a breath first um recursively and
so i need to create my own cue so i can
create a cue
kind of in a pinch i always just use
an array in javascript i'm going to
initialize that q with my source on it
so i'm going to refer to like source and
destination they're really nodes but in
the context of like our problem they're
really just given as strings but they
represent nodes right so think about the
information they represent
i'm going to iterate while my q is
non-empty so while q.length is bigger
than zero
should be familiar code very similar to
our tree algorithms and i start a single
iteration of breadth first by removing
the front of my queue so i can say q
dot shift so move the front i can call
that my current node that i'm traversing
through
and now that something has left the
queue typically here is where i check i
can check all right if that thing i just
visited if that is my destination then i
can just return true right i found the
thing i'm looking for so there must be a
path that connects my original source
and my destination
nice
but let's say this was not true well
then i need to consider its neighbors
so
like before to look at the neighbors
just key into your graph using the
source i can say graph square bracket
source that gives me an array of all of
the neighbors all the neighboring nodes
so what i want to do here is iterate
through every
neighbor over there
[Music]
and then i can just add them into my
queue so q dot push
that single neighbor and do be sure to
implement your true breath first so you
need to make things leave from one end
of your queue and you add to the other
end so this code's looking good
so you should realize how similar this
is to our old like binary tree breath
first except now we have to account for
the fact that we could have like a
dynamic uh amount of neighbors here not
just dot left and dot right so i'm just
iterating through all those neighbors
and adding them
i need a way to return false and you
guessed it the move is after you finish
this entire while loop if your queue
becomes empty then you must have
explored as far as you could and if you
never return true then now you can
return false because it must be the case
that there is no path between your
original source and your target so let's
give this a test run
we'll have a very similar time and space
complexity but this would be the code
for all of my
iterative fans so here i'm getting a
little error let's see what we did wrong
here so it looks like i timed out here
let's debug this one together if i had
to guess that means i did something
wrong getting trapped in an infinite
loop
this condition looks okay right q.length
greater than zero
and so ah here it is
must be the case that i'm not correctly
iterating through the neighbors here i
just wrote source
instead i need to say current because
now i'm doing this iteratively right so
whatever node has just left my queue i
consider that node's neighbors and add
them to be visited next through my cue
so let's give that a test run honest
mistake there
cool and there's our breath first
solution for this has path problem so
what i want you to do is practice both
the depth first and the breath first
like you expect we're going to do a lot
of graph problems coming up and
depending on you know what the problem
is asking sometimes we'll prefer one
type of algorithm over the other so it's
really important that you practice both
of these algorithms now while the
problems are relatively easy so practice
this give it a shot on your own and i'll
catch you in the next problem see you
there hey programmers alvin here right
now let's go over the approach for this
undirected path problem so i'll jump
right in in this problem we're going to
be given an edge list for a undirected
graph so if i'm familiar with the
terminology here really what we're
saying is every pair in this edge list
represents a connection between two
nodes for example if i look at the first
edge in the edge list i see i comma j
that means that there's a edge or
connection between i and j and since
this is an undirected graph not only can
i directly travel from i to j but i can
of course move from j to i so it really
represents a connection in both
directions and so as we start to attack
this problem i want to do is actually
convert this edgeless into a more
favorable format like an adjacency list
that's because typically when we perform
our traversal algorithms they work best
on an adjacency list form so let's start
by doing that conversion here that'll
actually be pretty easy to code up so i
want to basically generate a graph where
i have nodes as keys and i want them to
point to an array of their neighbors for
example if i wanted to convert the first
edge into an adjacency list form what i
can do is create keys for i and j i know
that i is a neighbor of j and also j is
a neighbor of i so i'm going to populate
those neighbors respectively
now i'll just follow this process for
another edge so if i look at the edge k
comma i i need to create a new key for k
and i'm going to populate that with i
and then for the existing key of i i
just add k into that collection so do
you bear in mind the most important
thing about this conversion is because
we know that the graph is going to be
undirected whenever you put a connection
within your graph make sure that you
have the inverse connection so if i have
an edge from k to i i also need to have
information for i to k
and this process would just continue for
the entire list of edges and by the end
of this conversion we'll end up with an
adjacency list just like this and now
we're ready to perform our main
algorithm when we go through the code
walkthrough for this i'll show you in
depth how you can actually create this
adjacency list
and so when we want to actually come up
with a traversal algorithm to solve a
graph problem it really helps if you
actually visualize the shape of your
graph so i actually want to visualize
this in terms of nodes and edges so that
means a bunch of circles and lines
between them so if you drew out a nice
picture for this graph information you
would end up with a diagram like so
and so we'll go through the rest of this
approach video just referencing this
diagram
something important i want to bring up
at this point is
for this graph a very common case you'll
have to handle is what if your graph has
a cycle and that's especially true for
your undirected graphs and so just for
the purposes of this approach video i'm
going to add an additional edge just so
we can talk about an explicit cycle so
i'm going to add one new edge from k to
j cool the reason is now there's a nice
big cycle of length three
highlighting it in red right now
and this cycle is important to watch out
for because if we don't do any special
handling we may get trapped in an
infinite traversal so imagine i started
at this k node and next i moved to j
then i would move to i and then back to
k
and then back to j and then i and so on
so that would give me a cycle we'll have
to guard against that
and so i can have a cycle of three nodes
here right and you can really have a
cycle of basically almost any size as
long as it's more than one so for
example if i took a look down here
notice that my graph actually contains
technically like two separate islands
but we would consider them as just one
giant graph right so if i look at the
small island of o and n they actually
form a trivial cycle right if i start a
traversal at o
from there i can move to n and because i
know that the edge between o and n is
bidirectional right it's an undirected
graph that means i can travel back to o
and then back to n and this would give
me cyclic behavior so i have to watch
out for all types of cycles in this
problem so in the context of this
problem not only are we given a graph
we're also going to take in a two nodes
so let's step through an example where i
want to return true or false is there a
path between i and l so i'm going to
mark those in my graph visual so i'm
going to start at the node of i and to
solve this one you can use any type of
traversal so either depth first or
breath first i'll step through
explicitly the depth first reversal
right now in order to avoid any infinite
traversals i want to mark my nodes as
visited as i travel through them so not
only do i situate myself at this source
node of i but i'm gonna mark it as
visited and you can implement this like
marking a visited pattern in a few
different ways when we code this up
later on we're probably going to use a
set to represent what we have visited
but for now i'll just check them off in
my diagram and so in my diagram if you
see a check mark next to a node that
means that i already have visited it so
since i'm at this node of i i want to
move to its neighbors so i'm going to
move to the neighbor of j
and i'll also be sure to check it off as
visited
at this point i can move to one of jay's
neighbors let's say i move to k
and i'm also going to mark it as visited
now that i'm at k i can move to a few
different neighbors i could either move
to i l or m let's say by chance i chose
i
and once i get to this i node i'm
immediately going to be able to see that
oh i visited this node previously so
what i should do
is not travel through i again instead i
should go back to the k right because
this i node is already visited and
that's where i actually avoid the
infinite loop
so instead i moved to some of k's other
neighbors let's say i chose the l
at this point i would mark it as visited
if i do a quick check i can see that
this node i'm at l is also my
destination node so i must have just
found a path between my source and the
destination so at this point if i find
my destination i can just return true
which is a pattern we spoke about in a
previous problem the only additional
criteria we need is to mark nodes as
visited that way we don't get trapped in
an infinite loop and that's only going
to be needed if we have cycles in our
graph which if they don't give us any
assumptions we should always guard
against so let's take a look at another
example let's say i had a source note of
k and my destination was o just looking
visually in the graph you can already
see that there's no way to get from k to
o because they're disconnected right
they're on separate islands let's step
through the algorithm regardless so i'm
going to start at k i'm going to mark it
as visited i'm going to visit some of
k's neighbors so i can move to i
then i can move to j and then at this
point i would move back to k and really
make sure that i don't explore any of
k's visited neighbors so i don't move
back to i right instead i should move to
an unvisited neighbor like l mark it as
visited then i only have one other node
to visit which would be this m node
and at this point i've actually
exhausted this full graph region right
there's nowhere else i can go
and once i finish my traversal if i
never find my destination node then i
can just return false right it must be
the case that there is no path that
exists from my source node to the
destination node that's really all there
is to this algorithm let's talk about
the complexity if we say that n is a
number of nodes let's also define that e
is the number of edges like we said
previously this is something typically
acceptable to do for our graph problems
i know that the time complexity is going
to be roughly of the number of edges and
my space complexity is going to be o of
n that is the number of nodes
i think it's worth stepping through you
know what this complexity actually means
we know big o refers to the worst case
so let's think about a worst case graph
that we can have and there are a few
different graphs that you can kind of
design and think of i'll just show you
one example so let's say i was given a
graph like this right
notice that although z is kind of on its
own island all of these nodes that is a3
as well as the z node they're all
members of the same graph
so let's say i wanted to figure out is
there a path between a and z
so if i did my traversal algorithm from
here i'll start at a then i move to b
and then to c and then to d
and then to e at this point i've covered
all of the edges in the graph remember
that the edges are the arrow heads here
because i have to travel through every
edge of this graph that's why we said
the time complexity in the worst case is
going to be
o of e right o of the number of edges
and here we can see that the space
complexity is o of n because if you were
doing this with either a depth first
stack or a breath first q
in the worst case you would have to add
everything you visited or that is all of
the nodes onto your stack or queue
that's why we say for regular graph
traversal algorithms we have a time
complexity of o of e and a space
complexity of o of n all right i think
we have the approach for this algorithm
down pat at this point you'll want to
join me in the walkthrough videos where
we can actually see how to implement
these visited patterns in some code i'll
see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over a javascript solution for
this undirected path problem
so i'll jump right in just like we said
in the approach video this is going to
be like a two-parter first we're going
to convert our edge list into an
adjacency list that way it's easier to
do a classic traversal through it
so i'm going to pretend i had a helper
function here that gives me back an
adjacency list i'll call it graph
and i'm going to call this helper
function will say build graph if i pass
it just all of my edges
i want it to do that conversion for me
so let's work on that helper function
right now and then we'll jump back to
undirected path
so
i'll create my build graph function just
going to take in the edges right
and i know i want my adjacency list to
be in the form of a plain old javascript
object so
create that graph object here i know i'm
going to return it by the end just like
this
and what i want to do is fill up this
graph with information from the edges so
i'm going to iterate through every edge
so for
let edge of edges so iterating through
every single edge i know a single edge
would be a pair so i'm just going to
destructure out of that
maybe just my two node identifiers we'll
call them a and b
from the edge
nice
what i want to do is now initialize
these nodes as keys of this graph object
so a would be something like this inode
or this k node right so what i'll do is
check if
a
is in my graph
i think really to clean up this code
would be better if i check if it's not
in the graph so
if the a note is not in the graph then
what i can do is initialize it in the
graph so use it as a key and assign it
to be an empty array
and i'll do the same for b over here
all right so i'm initializing a and b in
the graph if they don't exist and once i
do that then i can safely just add
neighbors into their their edges right
so i can say
graph square bracket a dot push
b
so now i'm saying that all right b
should be a neighbor of a but i know
that this is an undirected graph right
so that should be symmetric in other
words
then
make sure you push a into the neighbors
of b
so it's really important that you notice
that this is an undirected graph so your
adjacency list needs to be symmetric in
that way so if a is in b's neighbors b
should also be in a's neighbors
so that's looking pretty good let's go
ahead and see how
that graph looks just with a little
little side test here
so i'ma steal maybe this snippet
look at that full snippet here i can
just run it manually
i love to make sure i can test these
little helper functions before i use
them so i'll give this a run we should
just see the jason c-list form of
these edges here
let's see how it looks
so that looks pretty good so i'm seeing
that all right i is connected to j and k
right and that looks correct based on
these edges
awesome and i also want to make sure
that it's symmetric right so if i
and j are over here then i should have j
and i over here as well right it should
be a two-way street
all right now let's work in our real
algorithm here which would be some sort
of a traversal now that you have a nice
adjacency list you can do either a
breath first or a depth first reversal
i'm going to implement i think a depth
first typically for me it's just easier
to write especially if i do it
recursively
and so
i'm going to pretend i had a function
called has path
it's going to take in my graph now
and also
a start node and an endnote so i want to
find a path from node a to node b of
course i'm going to assume that this
function returns a boolean
but of course i have to write that
function for myself so let's say
organizing our code we'll say has path
i'm going to take in the graph as well
as node a and node b and i think a
better
name for these arguments if i'm doing
this recursively let's call this one
source and this one destination
so over time we're going to call
recursively and update this source node
and that should be a familiar pattern to
some other problems we solved recently
so think about my base case all right i
know that i have successfully found a
path when my source is equal to my
destination node if that's the case then
return true because i just found a path
otherwise i have to keep looking so i
should be able to look through
the neighbors of my source node so i can
say graph square bracket source right
remember that at any point through this
recursion source represents my current
position
if i say graph square bracket source
let's say source was i i'd be accessing
all of i's neighbors right so what i
want to do is really iterate for let
neighbor
in
or rather of graph of source
so if source is i on the first iteration
neighbor would be j second iteration
neighbor might be k
and for each of my neighbors i want to
travel to them so call has path you can
keep your graph argument the same you
need to change your source though now
you are situated at your neighbor and
your destination is fixed right you're
always trying to get to the same exact
node
i'm going to think about what type this
returns i know this is going to tell me
boolean right true or false is there
some path from my neighbor to the
destination
i'm going to check all right if that
call
returns true it'll be explicit here
then
i've just found a path so just return
that true right pass it all the way
back up
and kind of the logic that we form here
is i know that by definition
source and neighbor are definitely
connected so there's definitely a path
between them they're connected by a
direct edge
so if my neighbor has a path to the
destination then i know then the source
also has a path to the destination
awesome
and so after this for loop is done
running let's say we never
find that any of our neighbors
make a winning path
then that means i finish this for loop
without ever returning true which means
that i can return false right must be
the case that this source node
does not have some path to destination
so
i think we can go ahead and give this
code a test run
if you watch the approach video you'll
notice that there's something important
missing from this code but we'll just
run it and show you how to fish here so
here i'm getting an error edges is not
defined what i do horribly wrong
line 34 let's look at line 34 over here
so oh gotta take out this call
don't need that anymore
that's on me
let's get that test run
so that was not the error i was
expecting
i am expecting some sort of an infinite
loop though perfect i'm getting maximum
call stack size exceeded so i got like
an infinite recursion really
and that's going to occur because we
didn't account for the case where we
have cycles in our graph right we need
to avoid that because if i have a cycle
in my graph
i'm never going to hit any of these base
cases i'm just going to keep traveling
around in a circle and if that's unclear
make sure you watch the approach video
right
and so like we said the move here is to
add some sort of data that shows where
you've been previously
typically the way we do this for our
graph problems is to track some visited
set
so
when i make my top level call to this
has path i know that that is the actual
function that does the traversal
i'm going to pass along a new argument
here and i'll make it a new javascript
set so if you're unfamiliar with sets in
javascript they're really just a
collection of items and what's really
great about a set is in of one time i
can add something into the set and i can
also check for something within the set
which is going to be very very quick for
our traversal i don't want to use
something slow like an array because to
do a lookup or a check within an array
that would actually be of end time
whereas for a set it's o of one
so i'm going to make
a new argument here to receive i'll call
it visited
and what i want to do is all right check
if my source node is already in the
visited set to do that in javascript i
can check visited.has
so if the source node is inside of the
visited set then i could return false
here right there's no reason to travel
through this node anymore because if
it's unvisited then i must have traveled
it previously this is how i can avoid
any infinite recursion
and i can also move this line downward
if i wanted to
and let's say that i make it through
this if statement so that means that all
right this node source has not been
visited but i'm visiting it right now so
i need to do visited.add
source
so this expression checks if source is
invisited and this expression adds
source to the visited set
i want to change a few other details
here make sure that you pass along the
same visited set through all of your
recursive calls over here
because you want this visited set to be
like global for the entire traversal
right i need to know exactly where i've
been in the past
and once we have that in place that
should be everything we need to prevent
any any cycles from giving us infinite
recursion here let's give it a test run
awesome there's a solution for our
undirected
path problem so important things to take
away here do consider this problem a
two-parter right
phase one is really straightforward just
converting an edgeless into an adjacency
list which is actually an important
skill to practice because when it comes
to you know some problems you'll face in
the wild
they are all going to be basically graph
problems but sometimes they'll give you
the graph in like a different format and
you can always convert into a format
that you're comfortable with
then from there we have a really core
pattern of just doing a traversal
through a graph but also guarding
against infinite loops right and to do
that we just use some sort of a visited
set
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over the approach for this
connected components count problem
so in this problem we want to do is take
an adjacency list representing an
undirected graph as always with any
graph problem you want to start by
visualizing the actual graph and so if
you took a picture of this information
it would end up looking like a graph
with this structure
the first thing we should notice about
this visual graph is that it has
multiple connected components so for
example i can look at this component in
pink spanning just the one and two nodes
i can look at another component spanning
the four five six seven eight nodes and
finally a third component just covering
the three node that's why we say that
your result for your function here
should be three right because there are
three different connected components so
let's come up with an algorithm we can
use to count the components we know that
a general accounting algorithm is going
to use some variable and we'll
initialize that count variable to zero
and the trick here is to use a
combination of both some standard graph
traversal code maybe a depth first as
well as some iterative code
so what i'll do along the left hand side
is just list out all of my different
nodes
and what i'll do is start by iterating
through every node of this list
and what i'm going to do is when i'm
currently at some node of this iterative
list i'm going to start a traversal at
that node so right now starting at the
node of one i begin let's say a depth
first traversal you can really implement
this pattern using either a depth first
or a breath first so let's say i start
at the one note over here
what i should do now is continue this
traversal as far as possible that's the
key to victory here so from this one
note i can move to a neighbor of two
and of course as i travel through these
nodes i want to make sure that i mark
things as visited so i can avoid loops
and marking things as visited will also
ensure that we don't double count any
components here
once i hit that two note i've actually
completed this full component there's
nowhere else i can explore so at this
point i should increment my count by one
so whenever i complete a new
traversal on some region of the graph i
need to increment my count
at this point i now fall back to my
iterative code on the left-hand side and
i iterate through the next node so i now
look at node number two
if i take a look at node number two i
see that i already have it marked as
visited so that means i don't need to
start a traversal at that node so i
effectively skip the two and keep the
count the same
next iteration i have a three three is
unvisited right now so i should begin a
new traversal starting at this three
node which means i just mark it as
visited and since this three is a
singleton node right it's not connected
to anyone i would actually complete
their traversal just on this three node
at this point i've completed a traversal
so i increment my count by one so now i
have a total count of two
i fall back to my iterative code so i
move from the three node to the four
node and i see that this four node is
unvisited which again means i must begin
a traversal from this four node
i'm going to expand this traversal
starting at 4 as far as i can before i
go back to my iterative code right so
i'm going to explore the 6 explore this
5 explore the 7 and finally explore this
8.
at this point i've completed a traversal
so i can increment my count
up to three
and then i have to continue and fall
back to my iterative code so look at the
five node i see that the five node is
already marked as visited so i don't
start a traversal then i see that the
sixth node same thing don't need to
start reversal seven node already
visited eight node already visited and
at this point i would be done with the
entire algorithm and there's my final
count of three so a few interesting
mechanics here right you're gonna need
to definitely implement some code or
some function that does a traversal
through some component as far as
possible then you also need some
iterative code just to potentially begin
a traversal at every single starting
point
and what you want to do is be sure to
mark nodes as visited as you traverse
them because only when you mark a new
node as visited and complete that
traversal should you increment your
count you're probably wondering the
exact details of how we implement this
in some code but don't worry you'll
realize that it's really just a spin-off
of our previous graph algorithms in the
walkthrough video but for now if we say
that n is a number of nodes and e is the
number of edges like usual we know that
this is really just traversing now
through the entire graph so we can say
the time complexity is just o v and the
space complexity is of n right depending
on whether you do a breadth first or
depth first you're going to use that
space in terms of your stack or cube and
we can also consider using the space
within our set if you use a set to mark
your nodes as visited but overall it
still would lead to a linear time and
linear space solution all right i think
i'm ready to code this one up i'll see
you in the walkthrough video
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over a javascript solution for
this connected components count problem
and so we'll implement exactly the
strategy we spoke about in the approach
video so make sure you watch that first
we know that this is going to require
really two different mechanisms we're
going to need our iterative code just to
hop to different connected components
and we also need some traversal code to
just explore some single component as
far as possible
and so what i'll do here is let me start
with the iterative code so
i need to begin a traversal at every
potential node so i can say four let
node
of my graph and really essay in my graph
here because for this problem we're
given looks like javascript objects so
if i say for let node in graph that
would give me each of these keys like 0
1 5 and so on
and so for every node of the graph what
i want to do is begin a traversal so
i'm going to assume i have a function
here i'll call it explore
i'm going to pass in of course the graph
as well as that node and what i want
that function to do is do like a we'll
say adapt first traversal from that node
as far as possible
right so probably going to need to add
more logic into this main function but
for now i think it's about time to
actually flesh out explore
so i'll choose to do this explore method
recursively so we'll define explore
it's going to take in a graph as well as
my current node i'll just call it
current right
and then from there
i want to solve this one
using a depth first so recursion is fine
and not much to do here but really go
through my neighbors want to iterate
through every neighbor of this node so i
can say like neighbor of
graph of current
all right recall that graph would be an
adjacency list
so if current let me spread this out
so if current was a node like 8 then on
the first iteration neighbor would be 0.
next iteration neighbor would be 5. so
here i'm just going through all the
neighbors of my current node and i just
need to traverse to them so i can call
explore
pass along the same graph that doesn't
change but now my new current node would
be
that neighbor
just like that
and this will perform the baseline of
just the kind of depth first traversal
but we need to also mark things as
visited like we said in the approach
video that's a really important a part
of the solution
and i want this like visited set to be
global for my entire traversal
so i'm going to have to create it maybe
in my main function over here so i can
create my const visited
make it a javascript set because
javascript sets offer me of one lookup
and of1 edition
and i can pass this visited set by
reference into all of these calls over
here
so i know i'm going to receive visited
over here now
now i want to actually start using
visited so a few things to note right i
definitely want to use visited to
prevent cycles right that's one of the
main reasons we always add visited to
our graph traversals so some familiar
code here
if i've already visited this node so if
visited
has this current node then nothing much
to do here maybe just return false
later on we'll see
the really cool trick we use here by
returning false right it actually serves
two purposes
so return false because this might be a
cycle
and then i need to make sure that i pass
this visited set along over here as well
nice
and let's say that we have a current
node that is not visited so this
statement is false well then it seems to
be that we're visiting this node right
now so now we should add it
into the visited set
nice
and then beyond that we need to make
sure that our explore function is
consistent in its type right so what i'm
gonna have my explore function do is
it's going to return true
whenever
it explores like a new node return true
so if you take a look at this code
for
my function to hit this line 17 return
true then it must be the case that it
has already finished exploring all of
its neighbors right because i know that
this for loop does the job of exploring
all of the neighbors right so only after
all of those neighbor calls return
will i return true and that must mean
that i've explored this component as far
as possible right
and that seems good to go and what i can
do is now in my my main function when i
call explorer now it's going to give me
boolean data right if it's exploring a
new island or a new component it's going
to return true so i can check all right
if explorer
returns true then that's a new component
so i can probably increment some count
here i should have created so i'll say
let count equal zero
and i'm going to increment that count
when i find
a new component plus equals one by the
end i should of course return
that count
and what you'll notice is
for scenarios where we let's say iterate
into a node that we already explored
when i make this call
i know that that call is going to return
false because if something's already
explored it would have been added to
visited so that's why i'm using some
boolean return values for this recursive
function
so that code is looking pretty good
i think at this point we might be ready
to test this one let's give it a shot
here
so some pretty tricky code it's not very
long and this is a really core pattern
here looks like i'm getting an error we
have something wrong here so it looks
like the answer should have been two but
i gave back seven so i'm counting way
too high so what i'll do to debug this
one is really just
maybe print out my visited
so this is a very common mistake in
javascript
i'm going to bring in
i think this example
we can test it manually
what i want to be sure to do is maybe at
every iteration
of
let's say this this for loop
i console.log what visit it is we'll see
how visited changes every time
and i'll run this manually
by just hitting run
and let's see what we get here so a few
things to note
it looks like
some of our keys or some of our items of
the set are strings like the zero is a
string and other times they're actually
numbers notice that they're missing
quotes that has to do with you know kind
of just javascript objects technically
keys of a javascript object are going to
be always converted as strings although
the data within these arrays over here
is going to be number
and sets can actually store both types
and so if you have like two different
types it's not going to be able to
figure out like that those really
represent the same node for example
looking at this visited set over here i
have like the number one as well as the
string of one which is no good so let's
just convert them all to maybe strings
so i'll check visited if it has the
string version
of my current node so i'll just do the
conversion for me
and likewise i want to add the string
version of the current node over here
that way i have very consistent
types
so let's run that manually again we
should just see all of our
strings now
awesome and i think we can run all the
test cases so that's a really important
thing to watch out for in javascript and
javascript's pretty unique in that
regard it just automatically converts
all of your keys into strings awesome
all right programmers that's all i got
for this connected components count
problem what you want to do is really
practice this problem it's actually a
very very common uh interview question
and there are many variations of this
problem that we're going to do in the
future
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over an approach we can use
for this largest component problem so in
this problem we're going to take in a
graph just like we've been doing as of
late and the first thing you should
probably do is think of this graph as a
picture so hopefully you drew it out so
you can really understand what this is
asking
our graph information is already given
as an adjacency list so it's pretty easy
to draw out
so since i have a graph like this the
first thing i should notice is it could
contain multiple components right so
here i kind of see two separate islands
two separate components and i want to
consider the sizes of each respective
component so if i look at my first
component spanning the nodes 0 1 5 and 8
i know that they have a size of 4. there
the 4 represents the number of nodes
within that component so i'm really
interested in the number of nodes of a
component not necessarily the number of
edges
if i look at the other component that
spans the nodes two three and four that
definitely has a node group of three
and this problem really cares about the
largest component so i should just
return four because it's the largest
component size
so when it comes to what this question
is asking you do have some familiar
patterns if you've been following these
problems in order and of course i always
recommend that you do these problems in
order so how can we go about solving
this one
well i know i'm going to need some sort
of iterative code that way i can travel
and hop to different components or
different islands then i can probably do
some depth first traversal variation
that also finds the size of a connected
component so let's step through how this
algorithm might run on the side i'm
going to list out my nodes to represent
how i'm going to do the iterations to
begin a traversal at every node as my
starting point
so i'm going to start at node 0 and
since node 0 is unvisited right now i'm
going to begin a brand new traversal
starting at node 0.
and i'm going to mark my nodes as
visited as i go because like usual for
our undirected graphs you want to watch
out and prevent any cycles that you
might get trapped in and i know that
this depth first reversal is going to
explore this full region as far as
possible
and by the power of recursion it'll be
pretty easy to implement some pattern
that can count every node as we traverse
through it so i'm going to treat each of
these nodes as just being a single node
of course and eventually those ones are
going to return to my top level column
in which case i can add them all up
getting me a grand total of four
if this feels very hand wavy and you're
wondering like how the heck are we going
to code up that pattern don't worry it's
actually a pattern we've seen before and
so i'll cover that in detail in the code
just know for now it's actually not a
big deal to get the count of nodes right
so now that i know that the size of this
component is four what i should do is i
just store it as my current largest
island or component i've seen so far
because it's the first component that
i've considered
at this point i should fall back to my
iterative code so i look at the node of
one
what i should notice is this node one is
already checked off right it's already
visited so there's no reason to start
another traversal from this node because
if it's visited that means i have
already explored the component that node
1 is a member of so i can basically skip
it go on to node 2 in my iteration since
node 2 is unvisited i should begin a new
traversal over here
i know that this depth first reversal is
going to explore that component as far
as possible it's going to go ahead and
count all of those nodes as one and
eventually sum up those counts together
giving me a count of three and so this
next component has a size of three i
need to compare that three against my
current largest of four obviously the
four is bigger so the four gets to stay
as the largest
when i fall back to my iterative code i
get to my note of three
three's already visited so no reason to
start a new traversal
four is already visited so nothing to do
five is visited and of course eight is
visited as well at this point we're done
looking at every single node within our
graph and we must have explored every
single component so we can just return
the final value that we have stored in
that largest variable
awesome when it comes to the complexity
of this algorithm it's pretty
straightforward and it's basically
exactly all of the algorithms we've seen
so far we see that n is the number of
nodes and e is the number of edges we
know that the time complexity is going
to be roughly o of the number of edges
really just exploring through
the entire graph we can also say that
the space complexity is also going to be
linear really just o of n because
through all of this we're probably going
to be storing all of our nodes in a set
right the track visited and depending on
how you implement your traversal
algorithm whether you use a depth first
or breadth first you're also going to
use a linear amount of space
through your stack or your queue so
overall we're looking at a very
efficient uh linear solution
and so with that i think i'm ready to
code this one up what i want you to do
though first is possibly give this one a
shot on your own first because we're
really just utilizing some code that
we've seen in the past so give it a go
on your own if you get stuck you can
find me in the walkthrough video i'll
see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over a javascript solution for
this largest component problem
so this problem is going to be really
just a spin off of our last problem so
we'll hop right into it and as always
make sure you watch the approach video
first
and we'll start by building our code
that will help us start a traversal on
disconnected islands here right
disconnected components we should say
and so i'll start by iterating through
every node of the graph that means i
just iterate through the keys of my
input object here because remember we're
given this graph as already an adjacency
list so i can say four let node
in the graph
so that'll give me the nodes like 0 1 5
and so on
and what i'll do is i'm going to start a
traversal here right so i'm going to
pretend i had a function i'll call it
explorer size and if i give it the graph
information as well as the node that i
want to traverse through hopefully it
actually does a traversal through that
entire connected component right and
what i'm going to assume is let me
assume that this function actually
returns the size of that entire
component so that would be a number
right
representing the number of nodes in that
component
and so if i had that i should receive it
here call it size and i know i need some
like max value logic uh for this entire
for loop so i'm going to create let
longest initialize it to zero and then
from there i can check all right if the
size of the component i just found if
it's bigger than the longest then i can
replace
the longest simply longest equals size
then after the for loop i would just
return
the longest
of course i need to write this explore
size function
so i'll implement this as a type of
depth first so i'm going to make a
recursive explore size take in the graph
as well as our
current node
and a few things i should watch out for
here um they tell us that we have an
undirected graph and so we need to make
sure that we avoid
any cycles so what i'll also set up here
is
some classic structure i'm going to use
a visited set
i'm going to use a set because it gives
me of one lookup and of one insertion
so now that i have my visited set i can
pass that along as i start those
reversals and now let's work on a base
case so i'll do it to get going is a
check if i visited this node already so
if the visited set
already has this current node then i
need to return basically avoid a
recursive call but i also want a
consistent type here right so i'm
assuming that this function gives back a
number representing the size at some
point in my traversal if i get to a node
that has already been visited that means
i counted it already and so i'll treat
it as zero right now because i don't
want to double count my nodes right
otherwise would be inaccurate here and
now beyond that what i can do is maybe
create a variable here i'll call it size
i'm going to set that equal to 1
to represent the current node i'm on
right now right if this condition is not
true then it's the first time i'm seeing
this node so i need to count it
and we'll also be sure to do is add it
to visited that way i don't
get into a cycle into the node later on
nice
and at this point i need to make my
recursive call on the neighbors of this
node so like we usually do we could say
four-let neighbor of
the graph of node
so remember your shape of data here so
if node was
a key like 5 when i say a neighbor of
graph of node that would iterate through
the neighbors of 5 so 0 and then 8 and
so on
and so here i make my recursive calls
i'm going to call the same function
explore size pass along the same graph
but now you're situated at your neighbor
you can provide the same visited set
and here's where i do my recursive leap
of faith right i'm going to assume that
this explorer size function is working
so if it was working what would it give
back it would give me back a number
representing the size of that graph
right beginning at my neighbor
so whatever number i get back here i
just want to increment my size by that
right and that would accumulate a
basically a count of all of the nodes in
this fully connected component and after
i'm done exploring my neighbors i would
have explored the entire component fully
so i can just return
my final answer which would just be the
size over here
really important thing you need to do is
make sure if you follow this kind of
strategy you start your size equal to
one and you add to it over time because
this one represents the current node
that i'm at i know that every call is
going to count its own node so over time
this will actually accumulate everything
i need
so that feels pretty good we have our
nice visited logic and we already wrote
our main function here
notice how we're splitting up this code
in a nice little helper function here i
think it's the best way to express this
it's very similar to some previous
problems that we've done
all right i think at this point let's go
ahead and give this a shot
see what we get
should be able to put it through a few
different test cases nice and there we
have the largest component problem
so a few things i want to draw your eye
to remember that for your graph problems
where you have disconnected components
you're going to need not only your
traversal code but some just iterative a
mechanism usually just a loop to make
sure you can hop to different components
right because if you only had your
regular like traversal function by
definition there is no edge between
separate components so you would never
be able to explore the full graph
otherwise all right programmers practice
this and i'll catch you in the next one
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over an approach we can use for
the shortest path problem so here we
have another graph problem and your
graph is going to be given as an
edgeless so the first thing you should
probably do is of course visualize this
graph and in the context of your code it
probably would be best if you converted
it into an adjacency list since we've
seen that pattern a few times in some
recent problems i'll leave that part to
you we're going to end up with a graph
that looks like this and in this problem
we're also going to be given a two nodes
here let's say w and z
what i want to do is return the smallest
path
between these two nodes and here i have
two obvious paths right one way i can
get from w to z would be to go through x
and y
and there i can see that that path
length would be three do note here that
we're going to consider the path length
as the number of edges within the path
so not the number of nodes right so that
means how do i calculate three here
what's really just three lines right
three edges that's one way to get from w
to z another obvious way to get from w
to z would be to go through v in which
case i would only need to use two edges
so that path length is of course two in
this problem what i want to do is return
the smallest possible path length so i
should return the final answer of 2 here
so we know that this problem is going to
require us to do a graph pathfinding
algorithm and the question is which one
should we take we either can choose of
course a depth first reversal or a
breath first traversal i'll cut to the
chase here and both of them would
actually give you a strategy that works
meaning you can solve this with either a
depth first or a breadth first strategy
but maybe one of these algorithms would
be better than the other so let's
consider the possibilities
so let's say i had some large graph
we'll think abstractly right now so kind
of just looking at an abstract example
and let's say i was stepping through
some depth first traversal
let me say i have my starting node in
yellow and i'll have my target node in
blue so what i want to do is again
figure out what's the minimum path
distance between these two nodes
obviously you know just in the long run
you should get an answer like 2 here
right because 2 is definitely the
shortest path between these two nodes
if we did a depth first traversal i know
that depth first would force me to look
in one direction as far as possible
until i have to switch directions right
so from my starting note in yellow let's
say we move to the right that'd be one
edge and move to the right again two
edges move to the right again three
edges now at this point i can't move
right anymore so let's say we move
downward so i have four five six have to
switch directions again seven eight and
at this point we kind of already see
that this is going to end up possibly
getting to the blue target node but it
wouldn't be the shortest path something
unfortunate here is although my star and
end nodes are really close together a
depth first reversal could be unlucky in
that it may search in a totally wrong
direction and snake all the way through
the graph until it eventually finds my
target node at which point i definitely
don't have the shortest path
so i think a breadth first traversal is
going to be more useful here so let's
say i started at my green note still my
same starting point and if i did a
breath first traversal i know that
breath first means i'm going to explore
all the directions
very evenly so it would look like this
so i would explore all
nodes one edge away from my starting
point
and then from there i would begin to
explore all nodes two edges away from my
starting point
and at some point i'm going to hit my
target node and if it's the first time
i'm seeing my target node then by
definition i must have just found the
shortest path right the shortest path
would just be 2. so that's my high level
argument for why a breath first search
is going to be more useful in my opinion
for this problem
let's step through this process a little
more algorithmically so let's say i had
my original graph and if i'm going to do
a breadth first reversal i know that i
have to use a q right no matter what a q
is what gives you that breadth first
order
and what i'll do is as the items of my
queue i'm going to store not only the
nodes but also the distance from my
starting point so that means i'm going
to initialize my starting node on the q
along with the distance of zero and that
represents the fact that all right that
node of w is zero edges away from the
starting point because it itself is the
starting point
so any point in time the items of my
queue are always going to be pairs right
of node comma distance so now we can
begin our general algorithm i'm going to
keep iterating while my q is not empty a
single iteration of breadth first would
remove the front item of my queue and
i'll label it as my current node
at this point i should check alright is
my current node of w the thing i'm
looking for it's not so i need to
explore w's neighbors so i can look at
the x node
and i know i need to add it into my
queue but when i add it into my queue i
want to make sure i tag it with a
distance so if my current node has
distance zero i know that a neighbor of
this node would have distance one so i
just increment the current distance by
one
so on to my queue i put an item that
says x comma one
and i have a similar scenario for this v
note it's also a neighbor of w and so i
put v
comma one on my q as well
at this point i can go to my next
iteration remove the front of my queue
so i look at the x
and then i look at x's neighbors do bear
in mind that because i have an
undirected graph here x really has two
neighbors right it has w as a neighbor
as well as y so something you should
already know is i need to track visited
in other words when x is going to
consider its neighbors it should really
only care about the y right i don't want
x to put w back on the q because then i
would get an infinite cycle so i'm just
going to look at the y over here
i'm going to add it to my cube
because i know my current note of x has
a distance of one y must have a distance
of two always just incrementing the
distance by one
cool now carry on with this algorithm i
remove the front of my queue now which
would be the v note
and at this point i can consider these
neighbors and i do see that one of its
neighbors is actually the xena that's
the only unvisited neighbor
i'm going to be sure to add z into my q
and tag it with a distance of two right
because if my v has distance one its
neighbor would have a distance of one
greater
at this point you can already see how
this algorithm is going to work out
eventually this z node is going to leave
the queue and that would actually be my
target node so since i've added a node
into the queue that matches my target i
know i have my final answer the 2 here
does represent the number of edges we
took in that logical path
and i would of course just return that
too
so for the most part this algorithm just
sounds like a classic breath first
traversal using a q on a graph the only
interesting bit is now we're also going
to track the current distance you know
when it comes to counting the length of
a path you need some counting mechanism
and so if you begin your q with your
starting node with a distance of zero
every time something leaves the queue
and adds its neighbors it should
increment that distance by one and like
you already guessed this algorithm is
pretty efficient because we don't have
to traverse through the graph more than
one so we'll see that this has a linear
complexity
all right i think i have everything i
need to code up this one i'm sure you're
wondering about these implementation
details so what you want to do is
possibly give this implementation a shot
on your own and if you need some help
you can find me in those walkthrough
videos see you there
hey programmers alan here right now
let's go over a javascript solution for
the shortest path problem
so we'll jump right in hopefully you
watched the approach video
and so we'll start by converting our
edge list input into something more
useful for our traversal like an
adjacency list we're going to write a
very classic function i'm going to call
it build graph
like you expect it takes in the edges
and i want it to return an adjacency
list for me that means a javascript
object i'll call it graph
by the end of this function this little
helper i'm going to return the graph
and some common code i'm going to
iterate through every
pair right basically every edge
i'll say four let edge of edges
and as i'm entering through every edge
what i want to do is unpack that edge
into its component nodes i'll call it a
and b
and now i can start formatting my
adjacency list so i know i want
the keys of this graph to be obviously
the nodes and i want the values to be
an array of the neighbors of that node
so what i'll do is if it's the first
time i'm encountering a node i'll check
all right if
this a node if it's not in the graph yet
as a key then i should create it for the
first time
so use it as a key and initialize its
value to an empty array basically at the
start it's going to have no neighbors
likewise for b
and then at this point i know that a and
b now definitely exist as keys now
within the graph
and so i just want to add those
neighbors so if i have an edge like w
comma x i know x is a neighbor of w and
w is a neighbor of x so
simply put and say graph a
dot push b
and then just the inverse of that should
be good to go
cool so that should give us our graph
let's go ahead and use that in our main
function now so we'll just say graph
equals
build graph on the edges
and what we want to do now is actually
work in our breath first logic like we
said from the approach video
so a few things i'm going to need i'm
going to definitely set up my queue
we said that the key to victory here was
to not only store the node uh in your
queue but for every like frame inside of
your queue also store its distance from
node a
so i'll just use like a pair of things
so the elements of my queue are going to
be always a pair
and i'll throw on the initial node a and
also the number zero because at the
start right this node a is zero edges
away from itself so that's good to go
and over time i'm going to be
incrementing this number it seems
nice
and so let's keep on keeping on here
i'll write a while loop classic
condition would be all right while your
q is not empty
then i shall
remove something from the queue so
always remove from the front if you want
to follow a true uh breath first order
so i can do q dot shift
and that will give me back an array
right i'll give me back one of these sub
arrays here i know it's always going to
be a pair so i can just unpack
and i'll just say all right grab the
current node as well as the distance
nice i'm going to check the node here
that i just removed from the queue if
that node is
node b then i must have just found a
path
and i know the distance
in that path i can just return it but if
this condition is not true then i need
to keep searching
through my graph
so that means i need to add this node's
neighbors to the back of the cube so i'm
going to iterate remember that we have
an adjacency list the entire time
so i'm going to say
for let
say neighbor
of
graph of node so get all the neighbors
of this node and what i'll do is just
add those neighbors into my queue so q
dot push
neighbor
try to remember what the form of our
graph is over here
maybe as a quick little spot check
make sure on the same page let me just
console.log
the adjacency list let's say we took
this example manually
just paste it down below
then i'll just give it a nice little
manual run so i'm not running the test
cases
quite
yet so we converted this edge list into
this adjacency list right
and when we say
node is something like w
when we say graph square bracket node
that would give us this array
cool so we're just iterating through all
the neighbors of this node and adding
them to the cube one thing we should
watch out for is when we push
things back onto the queue we want to
maintain the same format so i actually
still want to maintain pairs so i'll
make the first element of the pair the
neighboring node and the second element
needs to be
the distance
and since it's a neighbor its distance
would be
plus one over here so that's how i'm
growing and counting the distance
so let's give this a test run there are
a few things we need to work on still
though
but we'll pass a few of these examples
at least
until we time out on a particular
example
one thing this code is missing is any
cycle prevention right and i know that
it's going to be a very common scenario
because i have an undirected graph right
and so what i'll be sure to do is
maintain a visited set
so a pattern that you're used to we're
just going to implement it for our
iterative breadth first right now
so start out with a set
and when you do this iteratively the
move would be
to make sure that if something is added
to the queue it should also be marked as
visited so if i initialize my queue with
node a then i also want to initialize my
visited set with node a just like so
so if you're unfamiliar with the set
constructor in javascript if you want to
initialize it with some values you
actually have to pass in an array
containing those values so the values of
my visited set are just going to be the
nodes right the node ids
cool
and then i want to work that logic into
my while loop
and so whenever
i'm about to add something into the
queue
that is when i'm going to add a neighbor
into the queue first check if that
neighbor is not visited yet so only if
not visited has neighbor
all right so only if this neighbor has
not yet been visited then i should add
it to my queue and if i'm about to add
it to the queue like we just said
anything that enters the queue should
immediately be marked as visited so here
i'll say visited.add the neighbor that
should avoid
adding any particular node more than
once into the cube avoiding any cycles
awesome so that feels pretty good let's
give that a test run now
so we hope to not time out at least
on that same example we're actually
returning undefined where we expect
negative one so if you look at the
actual prompt they tell us that all
right if you can't find a path between a
and b then you should return negative 1.
so if you look at example or test 0 4
and you kind of drew it out you would
see that there would be no such path
that connects b to g
the reason we're returning undefined
right now is
we're going to finish our traversal
meaning our queue is going to empty out
and then we're just going to hit the end
of this function and if i don't hit a
return line by default in javascript i'm
going to get undefined
so we know if we finish the while loop
and we never found node b
then we can just return negative one
that must mean that there is no such
path that connects a to b
so let's give this a test right now
and this should be our final version of
our shortest path algorithm awesome so
be sure to practice this algorithm
before you move on and do make sure
while you understand the choice of
breadth first here over depth first for
most of your basic just graph problems
that require you to calculate a shortest
path path meaning just the number of
edges typically you'll find breath first
the easiest way to calculate that
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over to the approach for this
island count problem
so in this problem we're going to be
given a 2d array representing a grid of
land and water so here we have l
characters representing land and w
characters representing water let's try
to visualize this
in this problem what we want to do is
return a number representing the number
of islands on the grid we're going to
consider an island as a vertical or
horizontal connected region of land so
in this particular example we should
return four because there are four
different islands we can label them as
such
this is going to be a new type of
problem for us and we should really
think about it as if we have a graph i'm
going to refer to these style problems
as a grid graph
and so although we're not given any
explicit like nodes and edges i can
still think about positions of this
graph as nodes so for example let's
consider
the indices here so i have my row
indices along the left hand side and my
column indices along the top
i can designate any position of this
grid using a pair of row and column so
for example if i looked at position 3
comma 4 that would be this position over
here
and what i should do is mentally think
about a position as if it's a node and
if i'm at some node i do have some
potential neighbors
given any position of this grid i have
at most four neighbors in the up down
left and right directions given any
position of the grid it's really easy to
determine what our potential neighbors
are it's really just a matter of adding
or subtracting one from either the row
or the column let's generalize this
formula so let's say i was at some
position we'll call it r c if i wanted
to go upward that would mean you
decrement the row by one keep the column
the same if you went down that would
mean increasing the row by one if you
went to the right that would be
increasing the column by one and if you
want to go left then you should just
decrease the column by one do bear in
mind that the top left position of our
grid is going to be zero zero and that's
why we have this type of arithmetic rule
so now that we're starting to frame this
grid problem as if it's a graph we can
use some common patterns i know that
this problem is really asking me to
count the number of connected components
or the number of islands on this grid so
i'm going to need some iterative code
probably some nested loops to just
iterate through every potential island
and start some traversal at that island
so when it comes to our iterative code
we just want nested loops to iterate
through every row column that means the
iterations should look something like
this
just moving left to right
until we finish a row in which case we
can go to the next row
let's actually iron out the main logic
that we need in our algorithm so let's
say we start our nested loops from the
very beginning what i do is check my
current position what i want to do is
check if my current position is land
right now it's water so i can just
continue on the next iteration i do have
some land position and since i'm on a
piece of land right now what i want to
do is explore this land region as far as
possible probably using some depth first
traversal and do bear in mind like most
of our undirected graph problems we're
going to need to be sure to mark things
as visited so we don't get trapped in
any infinite cycles so for example if i
start a traversal at this position
i can go downward but i can also go
upward from here and i can bounce back
between the two going up and down giving
me an infinite cycle so we know how to
fix this using all of our graph
mechanics right just use a visited set
so if i do a depth first traversal
starting at this position i know i'm
going to mark off all of these
land pieces as visited
and what i also want to do is make sure
that i increment a count representing
the fact that i've just explored some
new island fully so right now my count
zero since i just finished exploring
something now my count is one
at this point i can fall back to my
iterative code to scan for another
island so i move to the right it's water
so continue water continue now i have
another island and again i just do some
depth first reversal through it
and of course i increment my count
this pattern will follow right
eventually when i hit the new row
i could be at a land position but i
should also make sure that this land
position is unexplored right so since
i'm at position one comma zero and this
land has already been explored i don't
need to begin a depth first reversal and
i also don't need to begin a traversal
here and this continues
avoiding starting a traversal wherever i
have a visited piece of land
we know eventually we're going to hit a
new island like this one where i have a
piece of land that is unvisited so at
that point that's my criteria for
starting a new depth first reversal i
explore this region increment my count
and continue business as usual until i
hit this final island that is unvisited
so i visit it and increment my count and
by the end of my iterations i should
have my final count of four so that
logic is actually pretty straightforward
just a variation of our classic
connected component counting logic
except now we're adjusting the criteria
we use for looking at neighbors right
our neighbors are actually going to just
be either above downward to the left or
to the right of our current position
when we talk about the complexity of
this algorithm we should consider the
size of the input and the fact that it
has two dimensions right so if i say
that r is a number of rows and c is a
number of columns well then the
iterative code is pretty straightforward
i know that's going to give me r times c
iterations and if i also consider any
potential depth first traversal i do
starting at some land in the worst case
i could have one giant island which is
also going to be r times c so the
overall complexity is just going to be r
times c
the space complexity for a very similar
reason is r times c because imagine that
we mark all of these positions as
visited that probably means we'd have to
add them to some set right so i have r
times c different positions and by the
end i could add each and every one of
them into my set this space complexity
of r times c also includes any traversal
or related data structures like stacks
or queues depending on how you implement
this one so overall this is going to be
a very efficient solution to solve this
one what you should do is probably give
it a shot on your own first if you get
stuck you can find me in the walkthrough
videos i'll see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over a javascript walkthrough
for this island count problem so as
always make sure you watch the approach
video first
and we'll jump right in so we know this
is really just a spin-off of our kind of
graph connected components problems
except now we have a grid graph right i
can still think about like this grid as
if it's a graph because if i think about
any particular position of this grid i
know i have some neighboring positions
that i can travel through mainly my four
neighbors up down left and right for me
let me start by laying down some
iterative code that can begin a
traversal at every node or every
position of this grid that way i can
start considering different islands
right
so i'm going to use just a for loop for
this i'm going to iterate through every
possible row column combination so every
position so i'll say let r equal 0
iterate up to
the length of the grid so grade that
length do
r plus equals 1
and do something very similar for my
columns nested inside right
watch out for some details here though
looking at the examples we can't
actually assume that we always get a
square shaped grid square meaning like
as if the number of rows was the same as
the number of columns because sometimes
i'll have like an asymmetric
grid occasionally right if i look at
this very first one it looks like the
width is going to be 5 here but the
height is 6.
so
separately for the columns i want to
reference the column length over here so
i can say grid
0 length
nice and so at this point i have some
row column position i want to begin a
traversal let's say a depth first
traversal at that position so here's
where i invoke some like helper function
that we'll make in a little bit i'll
call it explore
and what's going to do is of course
taking the grid information
as well as the row column i want to
traverse through
nice
and at this point i think we'll actually
hop to building
this this helper function then we
probably need to fill out some more
logic within our main driver function
here
so
let's bake this
explore
helper function
so taking the grid and your row column
and something i should also consider is
because i know that this is really a
type of graph problem right i want to
prevent infinite cycles right so
consider this let's say i was somewhere
in the middle of my traversal let's say
i was at this
piece of land i know that this piece of
land is going to travel through its
right neighbor and it could be the case
that this piece of land now travels to
its left neighbor so i go left and then
right and then left and then right that
would give me an infinite loop right so
whenever you have this notion of like
undirected graph or undirected
connections then always guard with a
visited set we've seen this pattern
before so maybe up top globally for the
entire traversal i'll create a visited
set
so in javascript just send you set
you're probably wondering you know what
am i going to make the the members of
the set well i need to designate
positions right think about it as if
positions are like the nodes in this
grid in this graph right
and so what i'll do is
pass along
this visited set so i can accept it as
an arg over here
and when it comes to using your visited
set
what you want to do is make sure you
combine your row and column because
together they designate your actual
position
and i think this is actually worth going
through specifically more of like a
language thing in javascript compared to
other programming languages so quick
aside over here
let me give myself some more room
might be a while
because if you're unfamiliar with sets
and you don't kind of know their nuances
it might actually
hit you in the butt later on so let's
say i had
a set so i'll create i know set s get a
new set
and let's say i added i don't know like
an array containing a row column
position so i'm going to say is all
right maybe i had position i don't know
1 comma 3 and i added that into my set
so i do s dot add that position
this is actually a common gacha in
javascript if you put any like a
reference type so like an array or like
an object
into your set it's actually going to
check for
reference equality when you check for
existence later on in other words now i
can't really do
console.log
s dot has
one three
because this
array literal is technically a different
arranged memory so i wish i could get
like true back in this scenario but i'm
not going to get a true so we'll just
run that manually
see what we get
so like we say we're going to get a
false here which is not so good so
instead your fix would be to actually
convert this into some string data so
instead maybe
write as if you had one comma three
because strings are primitive types and
it would actually be able to
store that string so whenever i say the
string literal this would actually give
me a match now so i should get a a nice
true here
awesome
so we'll want to use that pattern to our
advantage
and so maybe i'll start by creating some
position variable that's going to be
like the stringified a version of our
position so just take my row
maybe add a comma
and then also
put the column here
nice and the reason i want to comma
separate is i need to have different
bounds for my row and column in other
words imagine i had a row of let's say
and i had a column of four
if i turn that into a key or position
that would give me position as it looks
like 12 comma 4.
another scenario let's say i had row 1
and then column 24.
that would give me a position
of
this right 1 comma 24.
right it's really important that you put
a comma to separate your row in column
positions because imagine i didn't put
the comma
then it would have a collision here
right i have two totally distinct
positions right 12 4 and 124 if i don't
put a comma
they look like they have the same
position key so that's why i need to
comma separate them common gotcha there
but now that i have this position
i can use it to my advantage in this
visited set
so if i've already visited this position
so if
my visited
has this position then i should exit
right i need to return something
and i want this explore function to do
something similar like we've done in our
old component problems i wanted to
return a boolean indicating whether or
not this is a new island that i'm
exploring so if it's visited already
that's definitely not new right so just
return false meaning it's not a new
island
if i make it past this if statement in
other words if position is not in
visited then i need to mark it as
visited right now so i can do visited
dot add this position
so now i have my core like cycle
prevention logic
beyond that i have a few other scenarios
we know that in our traversal we're
going to look at our different like
neighbors
and so what i want to do is make sure
that i'm in bounds here so i'm going to
check
i like to split this up into variables
i'll say i want a boolean variable
called row inbounds
and what i'll do is just check if zero
is less than or equal to the row
and
that row is strictly less than we'll say
the length of my grid
so i'm just checking to see if my
a position is in bounds here if i do a
quick check i need to be inclusive with
zero because zero is a totally valid
index right
i need to be exclusive with the length
because imagine i had a grid with length
five its last valid index is four so i
need to be strictly less than here
and i'll write a similar variable for my
column inbounds
just like this
[Music]
and at this point i can write a nice
semantic if statement and check all
right if your row is not in bounds
or your column is not in bounds
then exit right so return like before i
can return false right because i should
not consider like an invalid position
and out of bounds position as an island
right
so that's looking good final base case i
need though is what if my current
position is water right i only want to
do my traversal through land
and so i'll add another statement for
that so up here i can check
all right if my grid at row column if
it's equal to water then also return
false no reason to count it it's really
important that you put this inbounds
check before you index into
your grid right because imagine that
your row and column were out of bounds
if you write line 15 like this
immediately you're gonna get an out of
bounds error so start with your guard to
check if you're in bounds if you wanted
to because most of these conditionals
they all return false they have the same
consequence you can probably or them
together typically i like to keep them
separate that way i always remember to
write them typically for like your grid
graph problems this is very canonical
code
all right
so if i make it past all of these base
cases then i have the recursive case so
i must be at an unvisited piece of land
and what i want to do is do my depth
first traversal right so here's where i
explore my neighbors and i have four
neighbors
if i wanted to go above then i decrement
my row by one keep the column the same
pass along the same visited
because remember we have like the array
indices here so
this is row zero this is row one so
lower row numbers mean upward in the
same way lower column numbers mean to
the left
so this is up
this is down
if i do just minus one over here
that would be to the left
then plus one on the column would be to
the right
cool and i can keep this code very flat
as it is something that i'm a huge
proponent of when you write recursion
for the most part i always try to make
sure that i don't look before i leap in
other words just from this logic alone
it could be the case that rho minus 1 is
out of bounds but that's okay because if
it's out of bounds when i evaluate this
call it's going to immediately be caught
by this base case
right and if i express my logic like
this if i don't look before i leap if i
just leap and then catch myself with the
base case you don't have to write
repetitive code in other words
some people
write code like this where it's like all
right if r minus one inbounds kind of
using pseudocode here you would have to
write
row plus one inbounds and you would have
to write a guarding if statement around
every recursive call instead just write
one base case and you can catch all of
these
different out of bounds right
so that's why i prefer it this way
and so i know that by the time i return
out of these recursive calls i'm back at
this segment of my code and what i can
do is return true because i must be
finished with that a traversal and the
reason i'm returning true is true
symbolizes that i've just finished
exploring a brand new island so i need
to count it
nice it's also consistent with the data
type i have boolean for this explore
function
so for the most part this looks like
really just a spin off of our previous
like graph depth first code
and now i want to use that boolean data
in my main function here
so here's where i can actually count my
islands so
i guess i really need some logic here
that says initialize some count equal to
zero and whenever you find a new island
increment that counts so if i just have
found a new island i'm going to get back
true from this this call right because
remember that i'm beginning a traversal
starting at this row column position so
if it gives me back true then i can
totally increment my count by one
notice that whenever i begin a traversal
on a position i've seen before it would
have been added to visited before so i
would return
via this if statement on line 21 i
return false if i return false then i
don't
double count
that island
so i do need a combination of both
iterative code to potentially leap to
different islands but i can use a
visited set to prevent myself from
double counting any particular island
so this is looking pretty good let's not
forget to of course return our counts at
the end
let's give this a run this will probably
be the first in a series of these like
grid graph problems
really try to understand how we can
think about still a grid as if it's a
graph right we just have different rules
for how we look at our neighbors right
now a node is really a position and its
neighbors are its four neighbors up down
left and right all right programmers i
want you to practice this pattern
because we're going to see it in the
next few problems i'll leave it to you
see in the next one
hey programmers allen here right now
let's go over an approach for this
minimum island problem
so we're gonna be given here a grid
containing a water and land really just
some characters inside of our grid so of
course as always let's visualize this
and what i want to do in this problem is
return a number representing the minimum
island size we're going to consider an
island a connected region of vertical or
horizontally connected pieces of land so
for this particular input our answer
should be two looking at our grid i have
three separate islands and they all have
different sizes right sizes of four two
and five i just choose the smallest of
the islands so that would be the two
over here
so how can i actually come up with a
strategy for this one you should already
know that this is just a spin-off of our
previous a grid graph problem where
instead of doing just a count of the
number of islands now i want to find the
sizes of islands
i know to actually look at different
islands i'm going to need some nested
code but i'm also going to need some
depth first traversal code to explore a
single island so overall this should be
a pretty classic strategy for us
so let's say we started attacking this
we know we're going to begin our nested
loops in the top left corner
and if our current position is water
then we actually don't need to do
anything next iteration i have some land
at this point i can begin on my depth
first reversal and i know that i should
be marking things as visited to avoid
any infinite loops right so by the time
this traversal completes i'm going to
mark all of these guys as visited but i
also want to determine the size of this
entire island region
so every time i get a position that is
land i should treat it as one
and then when it comes to how i
implement on my traversal i can just
gather up these ones right just add them
all up so that would look something like
this
for my top level call for that traversal
i should get an island size of four
and so if that kind of uh traversal
algorithm especially how we compute the
size of the island is pretty hand wavy
don't worry when we actually go through
the code walk walkthrough it's just a
matter of some recursion and some
recursion we've actually seen before in
past problems of the course
but any case now that i have this island
size of four it's actually the first
island that i've seen and so i'm going
to consider it the min size so far but i
need to keep looking in case something
is smaller so move to the right so if
it's water i do nothing
water again do nothing now i have
another island so i begin my traversal
mark these as visited and when i find
the size of this island of course it's
going to give me 2.
i compare that 2 to my current min size
2 is smaller so i store 2 as the min
size so far
and we just continue business as usual
note that when we get to a piece of land
we really want to make sure that it's
land but also a piece of unvisited land
so right now i'm at piece of land but
it's visited so i should not where i
don't need to start a traversal here
likewise for this position
eventually though i'm going to hit some
new unvisited land in which case i
should begin my traversal
i'd explore this region
and i want to count up all these pieces
of land and i should realize that the
final size of this island
would be 5.
i can compare that 5 against my current
min
5 is bigger so the size of 2 gets to
stay and i can just end up returning the
minimum size by the end of this
algorithm basically representing this
island of size 2.
the complexity of this algorithm is
straightforward we should say that the
size of our input is r times c because
we have r rows and c columns in which
case the time complexity is simply a r
times c right we have to iterate through
every row column within the grid and
even when we begin a traversal in the
worst case we could have an island that
spans the entire grid in which case it
would also be
rc right so overall our full complexity
is r times c space complexity is r times
c as well and do know that this is
technically a linear solution in the
size of the grid right because the grid
itself is exactly r times c positions
so with that i think we're ready to code
this one up and try it on your own first
and if you get stuck i'll catch you in
the walkthrough videos see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now
let's go over a javascript walkthrough
for this minimum island problem so i'll
jump right in make sure you watch the
approach video as always this is just a
nice spin off of our classic island
hopping logic but for a grid graph right
and so let's start with the iterative
code that can help us begin a traversal
starting at every different position of
our grid so that just means some nested
loops so i'll start by iterating through
all of the rows and columns so r equals
zero
go up to while r is less than length of
the grid
and also do r plus equals one
and very similar loop
for my column
but do make sure that you reference
your inner column length because you
could have like a rectangular shaped
grid over here
and what i want to do now is begin a
traversal starting at every a row column
so i'm going to assume i have a helper
function here that does that traversal
i'm going to call it explore size that's
because
in the long run i'm interested in the
size of that island right so like a
number representing how big or how many
positions
that island spans so i'm going to pass
along the grid information as well as
the position
and i know when it comes to all of these
like undirected graph traversals should
probably guard against your loops and i
have some foresight here so i'm going to
pass along a nice visited set which i
can maintain globally for the entire
traversal because there's only a good
reason to explore a position once right
so i'll create const visited i'm going
to make it my nice javascript set
and a few reasons for that well for one
javascript set gives me of one lookup
but also of one insertion so it's going
to be a really quick data structure to
use
and from there you probably have to add
some more logic over here to actually do
something with the size but for now i
think i'm going to switch gears and
actually take a look at building this
helper function right
so i think the best way to build this
traversal is to use a depth first
typically just my go to for a problem
like this
it's going to take in i know the grid
the row and the column and also visited
i need some base cases very classic base
cases i'm going to start by checking if
this row column position is inbounds so
my favorite pattern for that is to split
up on some variables just makes it
easier to read and debug so i'm going to
say is my row inbounds i just make that
like a boolean variable
so i'll check if
let's say
0 is less than or equal to the row
and i need to say and right and
that row
should be strictly less than
the
grid length
so this boolean would only be true if
it's inbounds right and something very
similar for my call and bounds
[Music]
should be between zero and
grid zero length
nice just like this i believe
and then i can write a nice if statement
using both clauses so i can say all
right
if let's say your row is not in bounds
or your column is not in bounds
then you're definitely out of bounds so
you should probably use some base case
here right so what i'll choose to return
here is
zero because i want to keep a consistent
number right because this isn't return
type that is i know that this function
has a kind of goal of returning the size
of the export island size is a number so
even in my base case i need to make sure
i return some type of number returning 0
to represent that hey this is out of
bounds it's not going to contribute
anything into the the count of the size
right which is good to go
i need some other base case here what if
my position is inbounds but what if it's
actually water i don't want to count
that as well i only want to count
islands so land right
and so quick fix what i'll do is add a
new base case
i can check if my
grid
at row column if it's equal
to the water character so a capital w
then also return zero
now if you wanted to you can also maybe
merge these into like a single if
statement and just write a bunch of ores
i kind of like them separate because
it's just easy for me to remember what
each of them does right
a final condition i'll have here is all
right if i make it past both of these
base cases it might be the case that
this position is land but it's land i've
already visited so here's where i work
in my visited logic
i'm going to represent a position like
we said in the last episode
as really just a string so i can put it
as the members of my visited set so i'm
going to say position it's going to be
the row plus a comma
plus the column so just representing the
position
that's because i can't add like an array
into a visited set and then look it up
later
and so if visited has the position
then it's a duplicate position that i've
explored so return zero
otherwise it's not been visited yet so i
must be visiting it right now so i can
add it
nice so i have my base cases laid down
now i'll need my actual recursive code
so i'll explore my four neighbors by now
you should be familiar with this pattern
so
go upwards so row minus one column pass
along the same visited so i'm going to
explore my up down left right neighbors
respectively and i do my recursive leap
of faith here right so what type do i
expect back from these calls they're
going to give me back a number
representing the size of the island that
my neighbor is a part of but if my
neighbor is part of some larger island
then i am too because we're connected
right to our neighbors and so i want to
create the grand total of all of these
return values so i'm going to create
some size variable i'll say let size i'm
going to initialize it to 1 over here
it's going to be 1 and not 0 because the
1 represents my current position my row
column
and whatever these calls return
whatever number i'm just going to
increment my size by that number like so
then finally i can return
our total size
over here so that will do my depth first
reversal because it's recursive but it
will also tally up the nice size of this
island region
cool so now that i have a working
explore size helper
let's use it in our main function here
so i'm going to get back a number from
this call i'll call it my
respective size
and what's great about this logic is if
i have a
island or a position that i've already
seen before and i encounter it again in
this
this for loop then i would just return
early because i would hit this base case
right if something has already been
visited just automatically return zero
because i've already considered it no
reason to consider it again
but now i need my minimization logic
right i want the size of the smallest
island and they tell us in the problem
that we can totally assume that your
grid contains at least one island so i
think a great default value here is
to use positive infinity so i can set
some we'll say min size variable to be
positive infinity
javascript if i make it positive
infinity i know when i encounter any
like valid the island size it's going to
be less than infinity and it should
replace it
so now i can do some min logic here and
check all right if the size of this
island is less than the minimum size i
have seen so far then just replace that
min size
with
that island then after i'm done with all
of these traversals potential traversals
i'll return
my mint size
so some classic patterns here
there's one nuance that we're not
considering let's run the code and we
can debug it
together
so it looks like we failed example zero
zero so the very first example we
expected an answer of two we
accidentally gave back zero
if you look at that first example it's
pretty obvious that yeah the minimum
size is two representing this island
over here
the reason we're giving back zero is
according to our code
let's say we're on like the very first
iteration we can already spot it i know
that row is going to be 0 column's going
to be 0. that means my position would be
this w over here
when i make the recursive call
and i pass along position 0 0 i know
that it's going to immediately return
0 because that position is water
i'm going to check all right is that 0
less than infinity it is so i'm going to
replace min size with 0.
but if i think about it 0 doesn't even
represent a real island if an island has
a size of zero then it's not an island
at all it was a piece of water right
and so i want to add some additional
logic here to only actually look at
non-zero quantities
so only do the comparison if that size
is also valid so psi should be greater
than zero of course
and we'll want to and these together
so let's try that again
just a little little detail over there
that we need awesome and there we have a
solution for this minimum island problem
so we've seen this pattern a few times
now right our classic island hopping
logic so when you think about islands or
like connected components of a graph
this should be your first kind of go-to
algorithm all right programmers that
wraps up our course on graphs i hope you
learned a ton during the course i
definitely had a blast making it be sure
to head to shruti.net where you can
continue to practice more graph problems
as well as explore any other data
structure algorithm topics i'll see you
there